نتعرف على الفوارق بين محطتي الفضاء
الدوليه والمحطه الصينيه محطه التيان جونغ
الفضائيه الصينيه او القصر السماوي بلغه
المندرين الصينيه تتميز بحجم اصغر من
نظيراتها الدوليه ويكون حجمها يقارب خمس
حجمها يقارب خمس حجم المحطه الدوليه
وبينما تاسست محطه الفضاء الدوليه بين
عامي
1998 و 2011 كانت اول عمليه اطلاق لتركيب
المحطه الصينيه عام 2021 اما عن المدار
الذي تدور فيه المحطات فيتراوح بين 420
و450 كيلو مترا عن الارض اهميه محطه
الفضاء الصينيه تاتي من حداثتها وايضا
لانه من المتوقع ان تبقى في الفضاء ما لا
يقل عن عشر سنوات قابله للتمديد بينما
ستخرج محطه الفضاء الدوليه من الخدمه في
موعد اقصاه 230
الصين ذكرت انها لا تعتزم تكريس محطتها
الفضائيه لاغراض التعاون الدولي مثل محطه
الفضاء الدوليه لكنها رحبت بالتعاون
الاجنبي دون تحديد نوعه هنا يطرح التساؤل
لماذا ليست الصين جزءا من محطه الفضاء
الدوليه اصلا الامر يعود الى حظرها من
المشاركه في المحطه وفقا لقانون وولف الذي
اقره الكونغرس الامريكي عام 2011
ويحضر اي تعاون امريكي صيني في برنامج
الفضاء لمخاوف من سرقه التقنيه او اخطار
على الامن القومي ويرى خبراء ان الحضره
الامريكي اسهم في تسريع خطوات البرنامج
الصيني الذي يعمل على تشكيل المشهد
المتغير للقوه المتنافسه في الفضاء بهذا
يمتد التنافس بين الصين والغرب في كل
المجالات وصولا لغزو الفضاء
خاصه وان بكين تخطط لاطلاق تلسكوب فضاء
بحلول ديسمبر المقبل لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات